being from Argentina and being immersed
in Latin American politics for my entire
life
I know a little something about
supposedly populist strongmen dictators
Donald Trump has all the hallmarks of a
strongman dictator disguised as a
populist leader for the average guy
right let's just look at the different
elements that we have that really build
up this picture of Trump being a
disguised populist actually a strongman
dictator number one threats to su media
Trump has threatened to change libel
laws so that journalists could be quote
sued like they've never been sued before
Hallmark calling card of a strongman
dictator Donald Trump has expressed
distrust of the own the government
agencies that he will be overseeing this
includes the CIA and other intelligence
agencies again by itself not an
indicator of anything but as we start to
paint this picture of Trump as the
strongman dictator not something we can
ignore Donald Trump has been refusing
daily intelligence briefings from some
of these agencies on the basis that he's
like a smart person that is also
something that is part of the breeding
distrust of the government agencies that
you are overseeing Trump has expressed
distrust of the judicial system remember
when he questioned I think it was
Alfonso judge curial I forget his first
name I believe it was Alfonso questioned
the ability of an american-born judge
with Mexican parents to be able to be
fair in a lawsuit against Donald Trump
inherently because his parents are
Mexican distrust of the judicial system
yet another way in which these strong
men dictators when they don't just take
over the judicial system work to turn
popular opinion against some of the
basic institutions of a country Trump
has repeated fake news from fake news
websites totally undermining media
Donald Trump campaigned on populism and
immediately when he became
intellect made it clear from his
decisions and backtracking on proposed
campaign policies that he is creating an
oligarchical kleptocracy
to self enrich himself to further enrich
himself and the already rich and when he
started pat with the zero proof claim
that millions of non-citizens voted
illegally that's also an attack on our
voting system yeah and even with that
long list there are more that I can
think of because he's threatened to jail
his political opponents you know he's
sense backed off of that yeah he
suggested a registration system for
Muslims the list goes on and on it's a
very very long list and then remember
the suggestion during the campaign of
punishing women who have abortions and
then the suggestion well just just last
week or the week before about jailing
for a year or stripping citizenship from
people who burn the flag a
constitutionally protected action we
have a number of Republicans connected
to the real world who seem to realize
that this is a major problem independent
Republican candidate Evan McMullen
summed it up perfectly by saying quote
the most fundamental part of
authoritarianism is this idea that what
the authoritarian believes should go
they are the only Authority and that is
absolutely present with Donald Trump
remember he knew better than the
generals which by the way now he has
heavily loaded his cabinet with generals
yet another hallmark of the
authoritarian strongman dictator and
then the cherry on top is the crux of it
from saying multiple times during the
campaign I alone can fix the country's
problems this is the picture of the
authoritarian strongman dictator
attacking all aspects of government and
media su media can't trust intelligence
gotta do this gotta do that and I am the
only one who can fix it this is a
caricature of the Latin American
strongman dictator yeah and my concern
is once he takes office if he will
continue to push the envelope because
the Republicans have control of both
houses of Congress he's not going to
have
much of a check on his power know you'll
have some reasonable Republicans we've
seen Lindsey Graham John McCain come out
against certain aspects of what Trump
has said or proposed he will do but by
and large he is going to be unfettered
in his strongman authoritarianism huge
concern send me your thoughts about this
on Twitter at D Pakman